hello thank you for having me here I'm
just gonna make a very quick bowl how
many of you just raised your hands are
familiar with optical flow algorithms
and how many of you have an interest in
optical flows regardless of being
experienced okay very good thank you
so yes I'm a NASA postdoctoral program
fellow I started that two years ago and
I specialized in 200 physics and more
specifically into solar physics I study
the Sun I said these are sources of
solar flares and solar eruptions by
tracking the flow fields at the source
of these events why do we do that we do
that to understand the physics of our
nearest star the Sun and try to
understand how does the hot gas called
the plasma circulate on its surface
we want to know how the interacts with a
sort of magnetic field and finally how
our solar flares and eruptions triggered
can we predict them or more generally
can we hear them in the distance so I
will go back to the basics introducing
you to what is the surface of the Sun
what it's made of
and then I'll go into more detail
details into the algorithms for tracking
the flow is at solar surface I will also
give some details about algorithms to
track the magnetic flux on the Sun and
then there will be a little case study
to look for triggers and precursors of
solar flares so the surface of the Sun
the one you actually see by eye is
called the full of fear and temperature
is about five thousand five thousand
seven hundred degrees it's very thin
compared to the size the Sun is just one
hundred kilometres it's composed of
mostly hydrogen and helium so what what
you're looking at is an image taken from
the Solar Dynamics Observatory SDO
through an instrument called HMI
and it's in grayscale because the
detectors are monochromatic so it's very
chewy now how are presented I chose
grayscale the earth is on scale or if
you don't we know what the size the Sun
and let's look into more detail when you
when you look closer you start seeing a
sort of regular pattern and when you
look really close you actually see what
we call the regulation and so these
images are very high resolution and so
they are 4k by 4k images and the
instrument is sending them sending those
images to us with a cadence of 45 second
24/7 there is an another instrument
called aia it takes images of the corona
i will show that later but basically
these two instruments per day
send us one point five terabytes of data
so when you look at these dynamically
and here is an image series from another
satellite who takes even more height at
high resolution but with a smaller field
of view this is what the Sun looks like
but the photosphere looks like granules
these granules they move grow shrink can
explode and they there is also an
oscillation pattern now talk about that
later the size the granule is typically
one mega meter 1000 kilometers and their
lifetime is about 5 to 10 minutes that
means that after 5 to 10 minutes this
whole carpet of bones is completely
renewed
and tracking plasma at the solar surface
basically relies on tracking those the
motions of these granules one very one
of the very first technique to track
granules was to use so-called local
correlation tracking methods the local
operation tracking consists in
calculating a number the local
correlation to give you a number of how
much describing how much to areas
inconsequent if consecutive images look
alike and so the local displacements of
the local displacement of the feature
for example here from route from J to K
would be the one for reach that metric
is maximum and again that metric is
called the correlation but the problem
is as I said it's a number that tells
you by how much to areas in consecutive
images look alike but on that you know
granules they already look quite self
similar and that is actually enough to
fool this algorithm and so you ran a
book outliers because in those you know
little areas in which they look for
those displacements they can find twins
you know another granules that is
completely unrelated to the other one it
doesn't move there but it looks like
look enough the other one and that's how
you get our lawyer so this is a motion
that is not physical it is just because
the similarity metric which is not
robust enough and so that makes this
algorithm a little bit flawed for this
application I don't get me wrong for
other cases this is good if you you know
about correlation tracking it is just a
the nature of the data that makes
coalition tracking not so well adapted
so I've worked during my PhD some years
ago on another trig tracking technique
called ball tracking so I'm not the
original author of that but I have
developed that and lady even more even
better for this kind of application
these called ball tracking and so the
point of the purpose of bull tracking is
to track things more granules much more
accurately than local local person
tracking
the principle is to put but to throw
balls between the granules and we have
an equation of motion they would settle
into the local minima and as the
granules move grow shrink they push the
bolt around because it is trading in
this video which is not this is not
synthetic data this is actual real data
the carpet that's moving with the bumps
is actually directly taken from those
data that you have in the background and
how do we get the flow how do we get the
flow is we differentiate the final
positions of these balls to get a flow
field I will show you in more detail how
we do that first to be able to track the
granules with those balls we have to
rescale the data because these to the
images they have there are maps of
intensity and so they can they have
their ranges from thousands of over
thousands of data numbers we need to
rescale that so that you know from top
to bottom we have an intensity that
ranges much more which is more more
friendly so that the balls could settle
into these local minima and once you do
that using mean simply mean
normalization so you subtract by the
mean and you divide by the standard
deviation you obtain an intensity map
that when you look at entry look at it
in 3d looks like looks like this carpet
full of bumps and the initialization of
the trial rhythm is is very simple we
just have a regular grid just a mesh
grid that initiated so that you have an
equal spacing between the balls at the
beginning and there is a rule to put the
bolt on the surface and they basically
be the penetration of the data surface
into the ball is about 10% into the
radius of the ball so here is an
illustration of the principle of ball
tracking so each ball is animated by an
equation of motion the the forces are
the some sort of a restoring force that
is a function of the penetration
distance of the data surface into the
ball
so the more surface is into the the ball
the more it pushes it if it's a
symmetric the ball will move and that's
how they end up set
settling down into the local minima
gravity makes a gravity which is
completely unrelated to the sun's
gravity it's a numerical one is just
here to put to keep the ball down on the
surface
finally and more most importantly there
is damping the damping here is
proportional to the velocity and it is
to control the inertia of the ball and
gives us some degrees of freedom on how
tolerant we want to be with noise and
with this equation at each image we
integrate we integrate this equation of
motion they settle down in the local
minima and then the next image comes in
the granules have moved it it has moved
a little bit and we go again with that
equation and it continues following this
local minimum beware that we are
interested not in the velocity of the
ball in that equation we are actually
interested in the final position of the
ball and the velocity were looking for
is the one you get from differentiating
the final positions of the balls here is
an iteration of how one ball behave with
this in this carpet full of bones
and more importantly is that we're gonna
throw a lot of balls in the surface we
want to sample the whole map and so
they're going to be thousands of balls
and so for the algorithm to be efficient
it has to be it's best if it can be
vectorized that means to exploit the
fact that the equation of motion is
independent from one ball to the next
and having a vectorized code makes it
much more flexible if you want to
accelerate it using for example GPU
computing so you can see in this code
snippet there is not a single for loop
to compute the forces and the motion of
all the thousands of balls on the data
surface so that makes it very very quick
if you are bound to using say Python on
a desktop computer so to give you an
example one week of data which can be
about one terabyte actually it takes
about a few hours to compute with only
one CPU remember we're talking about
high res images every 45 seconds over
one week while local Croatian tracking
would takes many many weeks to process
that with a lower quality all right so
this is what the motion of the tracks of
the balls look like when you do not
filter or average that it looks like a
very stochastic motion that means like
some sort of a random walk and it's hard
to make sense of that because what
you're looking at here is simply the
intrinsic motions of the granules but
again when we do solar physics and in my
case I am NOT interested in the gret the
motion of the granules per se I am
interested in the drivers underneath
that I'm moving all these granules
around because this is what controls a
magnetic field and when you average
these displacements and you divide by by
time then you get the actual velocity
field and if you have rage that over
time and over space this is what you get
and to put in the context of the images
remember that we track granules
but what we derived are the flow fields
who seem to have a pattern that goes
beyond the characteristic size the
granules and this is invisible to the
naked eye but this is a real physical
structure that we call the super
granules the super granules is ours is
super convective flow cell that are
bigger than the size of Earth so to get
there it's not just about applying this
algorithm to the images many many
problems have to be solved everything is
done in Python the first step is to
filter the images when you look at that
you can see that the granules they are
not emerging you ously the intensity of
the granule is not a margin you see and
you can see some sort of an oscillation
pattern it's like it flickers and you
can filter that with full yay but if you
want to filter pure granulation signal
you need to basically sort of guess what
is a spatial scale you want to select
that you can get rid of the lower
frequency frequency oscillation in the
inner in the space sorry in the Fourier
space domain but where do you stop how
do you select these scales and so during
my PhD I did some random guess until it
looked nice but that was very
qualitative and so more recently a NASA
with other experts in image processing
it's only here you can use something
called the structural similarity index
and so that's one example how to know
that you you can stop well how you can
best select the scale that you want to
track so in this example you use that
but you filter the different images
until the self the structural similarity
index becomes constant and so basically
I stopped about there and so that even
if you filter even further you don't get
anything and so that's when you know
that you can stop and you don't want to
go too far because then you start
cutting down into the granule signal and
you want to keep those granule intact so
this is on the left the unfiltered
images and on the right the filtered
images where you have a mage more pure
granule signal so when you track that
you know that you are actually track
those granule and not something at lower
frequency again I'm talking about K
space for your space converting space to
frequencies and not time to frequency
alright another something else to solve
where's the missing bin problem so the
balls off to settle in the local minimum
but that means that if you have plenty
of granules they would end up converging
to the same local minimum and so you
would lose balls on the maximum because
they default from there they converge to
these local minima and at some point
then you're actually missing missing
some stuff so how do you how do you
solve that on the Left I've plotted the
what happens when you after the
integration of the balls and you have
all these empty bins and so these are
the bins that were you you you will not
be able to tell what the velocity is and
originally the original author tried to
solve this by simply throwing more balls
where they were and where he had empty
bins but still he still had and bottom
lots of empty bins so that was not
enough so for that you need to enforce
continuity by relocating the balls in
overpopulated bins into the depleted
beans while maintaining uniform density
and the constant number of balls so in
physics we call that continuity or
conservation of mass oops another
something else to improve was to have a
finer sampling for this if you remember
I was showing that with the images of
the granules I track the local minimum a
local minima a local minima would be in
those dark area they are the inter
granular lanes so the space that
separate the granules but still when you
do that you are bound to have the balls
settle there and always leave no matter
what
the centroid of the granules because
they are higher height so by inverting
simply the image the local maxima
becomes local minimum and so you just
drag both at the same time and in the
end your average all that
and you get a finer sampling now how do
you get a sense of the quality of the
tracking how do you get a sense of how
good you're doing in their tracking
because again there are plenty things
you can't really see and check by the
naked eye one way to do this is to
simply impose a drift on the data so if
you look carefully on these on the top
and bottom on the left is the filtered
one oh sorry the left is original one
the right the filtered one they sort of
here with respect to each other and so
these image series are simply but they
have simply a drift at a given velocity
and I've I've used like ten different
velocity drifts I make those series of
images drift at these known drift
velocity so that I can track each of
them I look at the average velocity and
I plot for the top side tracking and the
bottom side tracking I plot this curve
unfortunately the response is linear but
it is not a coefficient a linear
equation thority is not a correction
factor of one it is something like 1.3
1.4 because the balls take some time to
settle on the local minima and we don't
necessarily need to wait that they
really reach there on average that's
enough to make them settle say halfway
through because the next image anyway
they will be touching the other grains
are going to push them in another
direction so you don't really know to
settle down in the local minimum and so
that makes it more more efficient
because you don't need to have so many
integration steps to make them settle
down your local you know as long as you
perform this calibration and get those
calibration factors
all right so another qualitative
assessment of the accuracy and I'd like
to stress the point there which is quite
it's more an anecdote I talked about
precision of the algorithm and I'm
talking about accuracy and what's the
difference between there and you know
I'm not a native English speaker I might
refer
and funny thing is that in French when
you translate precision and accuracy you
get the same word called precision same
word and though it took me a while to
understand that when I was reading
physics books and so this rate the
difference is is very I like to compare
that with a simple experiment imagine
and I give a ruler to every one of you
but I have I'm giving you a ruler that
I've made myself and I ask you to
measure something say I don't know the
size of the chip of your phone you know
a nano-sim whatever and to give you the
numbers and you're gonna you're gonna
see lights a little bit around the true
value but is that the true value how do
I know the true value and how do we know
that that a ruler you have is good so
you can make a very precise measurement
with that ruler because you have very
good eyesight and so you make a very
precise measurement if you have a very
bad eyesight you're gonna have a
something not so good because it's gonna
be blur and you're gonna give me a
different number and then I'm gonna take
an average I'm gonna take the standard
deviation and that is a measurement of
precision the accuracy is how accurately
is my ruler how accurate is my ruler
that rule has been built and it's been
you know many many times ago the
reference for the meter was in Paris
called the Italo map and that's how
people were very braiding their ruler to
get the meter but you have to rely that
it's actually correct to make sure you
have an accurate measurement so under
Sun it's a bit it's even more important
because you can't check anything by eye
so in that example I've shown you how I
check the accuracy by having an
independent data set which is in the
background the magnetic field the
magnetic field is different data set and
we know that the boundaries of these
super granules are expected to
concentrate the magnetic flux and if you
plot the boundaries of the super granule
that you get from the velocity flow
field and I will show I'll show you
later how we do that you have a
qualitative assessment of the accuracy
so if you have these lanes that
corresponds to the where the magicfix
magnetic flux is meant to converge if
they do not line up with the high
concentration
flex for example here see at the top
they don't line up with that you may
have made a mistake
alright another way to compare is to use
simulation so these are qui veut plots
like shown one earlier Weaver plots is
simply a plot where you have arrows at
each velocity grid point and on the Left
it's the simulation physics simulation
of the granulation that has been for
which we just took the velocity flow
field compared to well city and compare
with ball tracking so the true value of
the velocity lies in the manage this
simulation you compare that with L city
local Garson tracking and ball tracking
and for example you can see that LCD has
trouble resolving the fine structure of
the of the flow patterns and ball
tracking is qualitatively doing a
slightly better job
and finally another way to a way to
optimize back to the precision is to use
the discrepancies between the top side
tracking and the bottom side tracking
and by minimizing this discrepancy into
the input space so the parameter space
that control the geometry of the ball
the physics of these model where the
ball set aligns to the local minima you
can actually get a set of ideal
parameters but it is quite robust you
can see for example here that is the
characteristic penetration depth its
characteristic to the dynamics of the
ball you can take some values but you do
not actually change much the precision
and that's because there is this
calibration process that makes sure that
you've done the job right all right so
how do we visualize these large-scale
patterns in of 2d flow fields in Python
so one example quicker plot map of
plenty of arrows is you some pattern
it's nice but it's not great because
it's very difficult to work with
components of vector fields and the ways
to look at streamlines but again it is a
visual aid the streamlines is a line
that is always tangential to the
velocity vector and the background is
the speed the magnitude of the velocity
so that another way to have a scalar map
of the pattern of the flow so you can
see that in the blue you are halfway
between the center of the super granule
and the boundary of the super granule
where again the horizontal velocity is
minimum but we know from all their
measurements that this is also where you
have down flows so where it's minimum
it's actually a down flow so it's
sinking down into the Sun another way to
have turns in the flow map is to use
derivatives it is actually the thing you
should not do it's very blur and it
people are very frustrated with that and
so we have to do better so one way to do
better is to use a convection cell
recognition algorithm where you simply
reverse the velocity and you integrate
the trajectories of that reversal ASSA T
and by doing the distance transform of
that
so that that means take putting the
final distance and mapping it to the
initial positions you end up with these
sort of maps where you have a lane where
you have convergence of flows and it's
very very useful I mean the results of
these map is the one at the bottom right
and you comes from that two fields there
so it is much more cleaner much more
easier to work with you can exploit that
in for data mining you can do some
segmentation to calculate the area of
the super granules try their centroid
and this way you have a good data set
for tracking the evolution of the Sun
over the solar cycle all right
next algorithm is how do we try to make
thick flux well we I still use the ball
tracking paradigm but on different data
so those are so-called Magneto grams
they map the photos for a cut of the
magnetic field more precisely the line
of sight magnetic field so that is one
component of the magnetic field vector
plus is widest positive black is
negative and these are both polarities
of the magnetic field and by rescaling
that you can also obtain a sort of
carpet full of holes but unlike granules
these are non homogeneously distributed
and so that's an added problem to these
optical flow tracking problem so with a
slightly different code you can still
track that in the non-homogenous grid so
you track the magnetic elements wherever
you have one with granule twas easy
because you know you had granules
everywhere so you can put balls you can
put balls anywhere and they would track
but here it's not the case nonetheless
thanks to the ball tracking paradigm you
can track efficiently and also have the
unique labeling of the moving magnetic
features and so that's a very difficult
problem for many image processing
problem trying to match and track
features
so these labeling problem is that when
you have two features you think you
track them you can get a velocity but
when you have many it's difficult to
keep track and to label them
independently and especially for having
a unique identity a unique label for
each other
for example in this problem you can see
that many of the magnetic elements
emerge or they close to route so when
you track one elements then close
throughout how do you do because you
have only one tracker at the beginning
and so with magnetic ball tracking it's
very easy because as soon as detects a
new feature you're gonna drop a ball on
there with a new label and so you get
you get a history and a tracking of each
independent magnetic fragments wherever
they come from whenever they rose
whenever they die don't die it just
disappeared all right so moving up to
active regions you're looking at the
application electric ball tracking with
an emerging active regions active
regions at what are giving you sunspots
so this is a region of very intense very
high magnetic field and magnetic ball
tracking can automate automate automate
the process of detecting them and
tracking and tracking them in this
example this is another way of looking
at the time series will result from
active all rankings on the left you have
all the magic elements that are tracked
on the on the middle it's a segmentation
of the track fragment and on the right
is a visual aid to check the tracking so
when you have it's called the I think
it's called color component labeling so
if you have a magnitude fragment who
doesn't change color of the over time
that means you've tracked it properly
because it's always associated the same
label that label is the same as the
numbers that you saw earlier except
there it's coded in a color table so
it's grabs a color in the color table if
it doesn't change color you're good you
tracked it if a single fragment over
time trendies color means you're wrong
tracking field
all right now I'd like to dive deeper
into a case study of sort of analyzing
solar eruptions so here I've plotted a
eruption of so-called filament eruption
we've observed with the another
instrument the aia instrument same
satellite but looking at a different
layer of the atmosphere hotter a layer
called the corona and blue stop there
and here i've combined three different
layers associated to as she's associated
them to RGB and so this is an artificial
artificially colored image you wouldn't
see that by eye temperature is millions
of degrees there in compared to the
photosphere who is just 2,000 degrees
and the case today is an x-class flare
so a very big flare that happened last
year and you can see it here it actually
is very bright and it's it's erupting
it's a lots of energy that are that were
directed toward Earth so it's called a
flare and at the base of the flare
you've got this little thingy there
these are sunspots and this is where the
magnetic field loops that are very hot
they emanate emanate from these sunspots
and so here is a case study of that
sunspot earlier in time where he was
still near the disk center i was looking
like this sort of called a flux rope
plenty of plenty of loops and with the
different tool that i showed you the
tracking of the flow fields detected
precursor phenomena ten days prior year
prior in the eruption
so on the left you see the flow fields
where I floated the streamlines coming
out of the sunspot the blue lanes on the
left and on the right are the result of
this algorithm applied on the flow
fields to get the boundaries of these
super granules and around the sunspot
you have also these these boundaries so
on the right you see the background it's
it is the magnetic field again
plus/minus opposite priorities and you
can see emergence very strong emergence
of magnetic flux and this is where this
is the source of the energy that is
later released in the soil layer the
point of the algorithms is to study the
flows that are the evolution of the
flows around the sunspot and you think
these series using the framework the
tracking framework we could analyze and
detect that before the emergence of
magnetic flux there is a disruption of
the pattern of the flow fields that are
plotted here with both the boundaries of
the flows and the streamlines of the
flows with their qui veut plots of the
arrows and you can see that it's some so
it's sort of escaping away from the
sunspot the center is around there and
later on you have the emergence of magic
flux the magic flux starts to emerge at
that point there so with these
algorithms we can detect the emergence
of magnetic flux several hours before it
happens and so this is an example
another example or you have here the
boundaries that flows around since but
are quiet and they're down there you see
a bulge and here a stronger bulge and
that is pre cursing the emergence of
magic fluids in black and white
so the summarize so if shown you hear
examples written in Python of
application of optical flow tracking
algorithms for analyzing the solar
plasma formal observations and they
provide us new descriptors of a solar
activity for example the battery is a
super gorilla flows and the flows around
the sunspot which is called a mode flow
we can analyze the properties of the
magnetic field through a curt tracking
labeling and segmentation of matrix
elements that peer through and flow over
the photosphere
so that calls lots of different
background computer vision because there
is segmentation there physics because
you need to implement a physics away or
algorithms and so these descriptors are
meant to become input to machine
learning and deep learning for assessing
the ability to focus flares through
statistical analysis so if you're
experiencing solar flows and oh sorry in
optical slows in general and you want to
try tracking SDO data and so the flows
with your algorithm please feel free to
do so the data are freely available my
tracking framework if you want to try
that about the data or we want to play
with that and prove that if you have
nothing else to do
it's available freely it's on the bucket
and if you have questions you can
contact me I'm on LinkedIn email me at
NASA we're really happy to discuss all
that thank you very much for attention
[Applause]
yep
no it's not so it's stuck in the inner
loop there is no inner loop but there is
the outer loop it loops over the images
yes it's the only loop that there is no
I even that would be it'll be great yeah
it's it's fast enough though this way
well I mentioned the benchmark on one
CPU but in fact typically use for CPU
the four CPUs are meant to you for
example track you know the the top side
tracking and the bottom side tracking
these are parallel and they can be it's
paralyzed and so that makes it even
faster but yeah that would be great to
have the time also vectorized the
maximum what okay so we are limited by
projection effects so in terms of image
size the maximum I can do at a time
would be 1k by 1k because then beyond
that the granules and their good
projection effects and so you're losing
resolution if you're looking at them on
this side and so one pixel doesn't have
the same physical scale as in this disc
center and so the maximum is 1k by 1k so
that's you know the full Sun would be
nearly 1/4 K by 4k so that's like 1/8 in
surface wins 160
what's that
yeah yes we yes and we yeah we don't
have them fortunately yeah so yeah
because the point is not to model the
alert yeah
so nobody do not collide did they go
through there is one point in mention
because it was a bit too technical is
that to be able to relocate repopulate
the empty bins there needs to be some
internal communication between the boss
to know where each other are but
fortunately minutes I'll also vectorize
that so it's also very very fast so
using this sort of course great thing in
which you have this bigger grid cell and
you check that you just make sure you
have at any time one in those one ball
in each of those cell that's how I
relocated them they pass yeah because
they can yes they can come from
different points and so they can they
can come from opposite velocity or
positive directions but once they settle
down is the same they will stay the same
positions right and at that point then I
really keep one ball tracking that place
in the other ball that I've converged
there that there are the very ones that
are relocated elsewhere to continue
tracking on the depleted bins
okay to be fair they are some of what
you saw was from historical my her
satirical research in it was MATLAB the
more recent one like for example this
one there it's with my avi the one you
see right now like for the flows it's
with maya VI the i have a problem it was
a streamline so you see those colored
lines though it's called
the streamlines i have a problem with
matplotlib implementation of streamlines
i can tell you there is actually not a
bug but a mistake physics mistake and so
when you plot streamlines in matplotlib
well I actually did recommend you to do
so there is something wrong there and so
that's why you had to use another
package and matplotlib it's it's a
problem for me because the maya VI is a
3d visualization software I'm using it
for 2d projections it's highly
inefficient for that and I have to play
around with the camera I don't like that
because I'm using truly 2d data your
other question was for other
visualizations so the other plots that
you saw was done with my plot clip for
the videos that you saw the quick just a
quiver plot with arrows that was also
with MATLAB
I try that it kills it is theoretically
possible right but then you can't have a
constant side of the balls because you
need to compensate for the change of the
ellipse of transformation you do
protection effects because you if you
have a constant size of balls to track a
feature that has a constant size on
average you're losing a resolution and
so this wouldn't compensate for that so
when I tried that I had I was completely
wrong and so I need to remap and yeah I
come to beat on a sphere
extend what
so yeah that's actually where things
come into play I'm not just trying to
I'm not trying to predict whether it's
gonna fly or not yes this whole thing it
is to quantify the energy that could be
released should it leerin should it
flare if it flares how much energy
should I expect because by tracking the
flows you have a vantage point on the
kinetic energy that gets converted into
magnetic stress and this is what
accumulates energy before a flare yeah
we have to continue later